I've now done a bunch of videos on
thermodynamics posed both in the
chemistry and the physics playlist and I
realize that I have yet to give you or
at least if my memory serves me
correctly I have yet to give you the
first law of thermodynamics and I think
now is as good a time as any the first
law of thermodynamics thermodynamics and
it's a good one it tells us that energy
energy I'll do it in in in this magenta
color energy cannot be created or
destroyed it can only be transformed
from one form or another so energy
cannot be created or destroyed only
transformed only transformed so let's
think about a couple of examples of this
and we've touched on this when we
learned mechanics and kinetics in our in
our in our physics playlist and we've
done a bunch of this in the in the
chemistry playlist as well so let's say
I have some rock that I just throw as
fast as I can straight up
maybe it's a ball of some kind so I
throw a ball straight up that arrow
represents its velocity vector right
it's going to go up in the air maybe I
let me do it here I throw a ball and
it's going to go up in the air it's
going to decelerate due to gravity and
at some point up here the ball is not
going to have any velocity so at this
point it's going to slow down a little
bit at this point is going to slow down
a little bit more and at this points
going to be completely stationary and
then it's going to start accelerating
downwards in fact it was always
accelerating downwards it was
decelerating upwards and then will start
accelerating downwards so here it's
velocity will look like that and here
it's velocity you look like that and
then right when it gets back to the
ground if we assume negligible air
resistance its velocity will be the same
magnitude as the upward but in the
downward direction so when we looked at
this example and we've done this tons in
the projectile motion videos in the chem
in the physics playlist over here we
said look we have some kinetic energy
here
and that makes sense I think to all of
us energy intuitively means that you're
doing something so kinetic energy energy
of movement of kinetics right it's
moving so it has energy but then as we
decelerate up here we clearly have no
kinetic energy zero kinetic energy zero
kinetic energy so where did our energy
go I just told you the first law of
thermodynamics that energy cannot be
created or destroyed but I clearly had a
lot of kinetic energy over here and
we've seen the formula for that multiple
times and here I have no kinetic energy
so I clearly destroyed kinetic energy
but the first law of thermodynamics
tells me that I can't do that so I must
have transformed that kinetic energy
I must have transformed that kinetic
energy into something else and in the
case of this ball I've transformed it
into potential energy so now I have
potential energy and I will go into the
math of it but potential energy is just
the potential the the potential to to
turn into other forms of energy I guess
it's the easy way to do it but the way
to think about it is look the ball is
really high up here and by virtue of its
position in the universe it's if
something doesn't stop it it's going to
fall back down or it's going to be
converted into another form of energy
now let me ask you another question
let's say I throw this ball up and let's
say we actually do have some air
resistance so I throw the ball up I have
a lot of kinetic energy here so I have
kinetic energy here then at the peak of
the of where the ball is it's all
potential energy it's the kinetic
energies disappeared and let's say I
have air resistance so when the ball
comes back down the air was kind of
slowing it down so it doesn't go so when
it reaches this bottom point it's not
going as fast as I threw it so when I
reach this bottom point here my ball is
going a lot slower than I threw it up to
begin with and so if you think about
what happened I have a lot of kinetic
energy here I'll give you the formula
the kinetic energy is a mass of the ball
times the velocity of the ball squared
over two that's the kinetic energy over
here and then I throw it it all turns
into potential energy and then it comes
back down turns into kinetic energy but
because of air resistance I have a
smaller
ASSA tea here I have a smaller velocity
here than I did their kinetic energy is
only depend on the magnitude of the
velocity I could put a little no
absolute sign there so that we're
dealing with the magnitude of the
velocity so I clearly have a lower
kinetic energy here so lower kinetic
energy lower kinetic energy here then I
did here right and I don't have any
potential energy left let's say this is
the ground we've hit the ground so I
have another conundrum you know when I
went from kinetic energy to no kinetic
energy there I could go to the first law
and say oh what happened the first law
says Oh salad it all turned into
potential energy up here and then and
you saw it turned into potential energy
because in the ball accelerated back
down and turn back into kinetic energy
but now I say no mister first law of
thermodynamics look at this point I have
no potential energy and I had all
kinetic energy and I had a lot of
kinetic energy now at this point I have
no potential energy once again but I
have less kinetic energy my ball has
fallen at a slower rate than I threw it
to begin with
and and the thermodynamic says oh well
that's because you have air and not say
well I do have air but where did the
energy go
and then the first law of thermodynamics
says oh the the your your when your ball
was falling the ball was Flemmi see
let's see the the best the ball let me
get the ball yellow so when your ball
was falling it was rubbing up against
air particles it was rubbing up against
molecules of air right and right where
the molecules bumped into the wall
there's a little bit of friction
friction is just essentially your ball
made these molecules that it was bumping
into vibrate a little bit faster it
essentially if you think about it if we
if you go back to the macro state
microstate problem or descriptions that
we talked about these balls this ball is
essentially transferring its kinetic
energy to the molecules of air that it
rubs up against as it falls back down
and actually was doing it on the way up
as well and so that kinetic energy that
you think you lost or you destroy it at
the bottom of here because your balls
going a lot slower was actually
transferred to a lot of air particles it
was a lot of to a bunch of air
giggles now it's next to impossible to
measure exactly the kinetic energy that
was done on each individual air particle
because we don't even know what their
microstates were to begin with but we
can say is in general I transferred some
heat to these particles I raised the
temperature of the of the of the of the
of the air particles that the ball felt
through by by by rubbing those particles
or giving them kinetic energy remember
temperature is just a measure of kinetic
and it temperature is a macrostate or
kind of a gross way or a macro way of
looking at the kinetic energy of the
individual molecules it's very hard to
measure each of theirs but if say on
average their kinetic energy is X you're
essentially giving an indication of
temperature so that's where it went it
went to heat and heat is another form of
energy so the first law of
thermodynamics says I still hold you had
Pinet you had a lot of kinetic energy
turned into potential that turned into
less kinetic energy and where did the
the remainder go it turned into heat
because it transferred that kinetic
energy to these two these air particles
or in the surrounding medium fair enough
so now that we have that out of the way
how do we measure the amount of energy
that something contains measure the
amount of energy and here we have
something called the internal energy
internal energy of a system once again
this is a macro macro state or you can
call it a macro description of what's
going on this is called U for internal
the way I remember that is that the word
internal does not begin with the u U for
internal energy internal energy U for
internal energy and it literally is if I
have let me go back to my example that I
had in the past that I did in our
previous video you're watching these in
order of I have you know some gas in a
say I have some gas with some movable
ceiling at the top that's its movable
ceiling that can move up and down we
have a vacuum up there and I have some
gas in here I have some gas in here the
internal energy literally is all of the
energy that's in this system so
it includes and for our purposes
especially when you're in a first-year
chemistry course and it's the kinetic
energy kinetic energy of all the atoms
or molecules atoms or molecules and in a
future video I'll actually calculate it
for you know how much kinetic energy is
there in a container and that'll
actually be our internal energy plus all
of the other energy so these atoms you
know they have some kinetic energy
because they have some translational
motion if we look at the microstate if
they're if they're just individual atoms
you can't really say that they're
rotating because what does it mean for
an atom to rotate right because it's
electrons or just jumping around anyway
so if they're individual atoms they
can't rotate but if there are molecules
they can rotate if it looks something
like that
there could be some rotational energy
there it includes that if we have bonds
so I just drew a molecule the molecule
has bonds those bonds contain some
energy that is also included in the
internal energy if I have some electrons
let's say that this was not a let's well
I'm doing it using a gas and gases
aren't good conductors but let's say I'm
doing it for a a solid oh I'm using the
wrong tool so let's say I have a bunch
of let's say I have some metal all right
those are my metal let me do more my
metal atoms and in that metal atoms I in
that metal atom I have you know a bunch
of electrons it's the same color I have
a bunch of uses a suitably different
color I have a bunch of electrons here
and I have fewer here so these electrons
really want to get here maybe they're
being stopped for some reason so they
have some electrical potential maybe
there's a gap here you know where they
can't conduct or something like that
internal energy includes that as well
that's normally the scope out of what
you'd see in a first-year chemistry
class but it includes that it also
includes includes literally every form
of energy that exists it also includes
for example in a metal if we were to
heat this metal up they start vibrating
right they start moving left and right
or up or down or in every possible
direction and if you think about a
molecule or an atom that's vibrating
it's going from here and then it goes
there then it goes back there it goes
back and forth right and if you think
about what's happening when it's in the
middle point has a lot of kinetic energy
but at this point right here when it's
about to go back it's completely
stationary for you know a super small
moment and at that point all of its
kinetic energy is potential energy and
then it turns into kinetic energy then
it goes back to potential energy again
it's kind of like a pendulum or it's
it's actually harmonic motion so in this
case internal energy also includes it
includes the the kinetic energy for the
molecules that are moving fast but it
also includes the potential energies for
the molecules that are vibrating but it
there at that point where they don't
have kinetic energy so it also includes
potential energy so internal energy is
literally all of the energy that's in a
system that's in a system and and and
for most of what we're going to do you
can assume that we're dealing with an
ideal gas instead you know becomes a lot
more complicated with solids and
conductivity and vibrations and all that
we're going to assume we're dealing with
an ideal gas and even a better we're
going to assume what we're dealing with
in a monoatomic ideal gas so maybe this
is just helium helium or neon one of the
ideal gases they don't want to bond with
each other they don't form molecules
with each other or in in in you know
well let's just assume that they're not
they're just individual individual atoms
right in that case the internal energy
we really can simplify to it being the
kinetic energy if we ignore all of these
other things but it's important to
realize the internal energy is
everything it's all of the energy inside
of the system it's it's it's it's you
know it's it's if you said what's the
energy system its internal energy so if
in the the first law of thermodynamics
says that energy cannot be created or
destroyed only transformed so let's say
that internal energy is changing so I
have this system and someone tells me
look the internal energy is changing so
Delta U that's just a capital Delta that
says what is the change in internal
energy saying look if your internal
energy is changing your system is either
having something done to it or it's
doing something to someone else some
energy is being transferred to
or away from it so how do we write that
well the first law of thermodynamics or
even the definition of internal energy
says that a change in internal energy is
equal to heat added to the system and
once again very intuitive a letter for
heat because heat does not start with Q
but the convention is is to use Q for
heat the letter H is reserved for
enthalpy which is a very very very
similar concept to heat we'll talk about
that in the next video it's equal to the
heat added to the system minus the work
done by the system minus the work done
by the system and you can see this
multiple way sometimes it's written like
this sometimes it's written that the
change in enthalpy is equal to the heat
added to the system plus plus the work
done on the system and this might be
very confusing but the you should just
always and we'll really kind of look at
this 100 different ways in the next
video and actually this is a capital u
let me make sure that I write that as a
capital u we're gonna do it a hundred
different ways but if you think about it
if I'm doing work I lose energy I have
transferred the energy to someone else
so this is doing work doing work
likewise if someone is giving me heat
that is increasing my energy at least to
me that these are reasonably intuitive
definitions now if you see this you say
okay how can I this must be if my energy
is going up if this is a positive thing
I either have to have this go up or work
is being done to me work done to me done
to me or energy is being transferred
into my system and I'll become I'll give
a lot more examples of what exactly that
means in the next video but I just want
to make you comfortable with each of
these because our going to see them all
the time and you might even get confused
even if your teacher uses only one of
them but you should always do this
reality check when something does work
it is transferring energy to something
else right so if you're doing work it'll
take away this is taking away your
internal energy
likewise if
what heat transfer is another way for
for energy to go from one system to
another from one entity to another so if
my energy my total energy is going up my
Heat maybe heat is being added to my
system if my energy is going down my
energy is going down either heat is
being taken away from my system or I am
doing more work on something and I'll do
a bunch of examples with that and I'm
just going to leave you in this video
with some other notations that you might
see you might see change in internal
energy is equal to change I shouldn't I
keep writing a let me write it again
change in internal energy capital u
you'll sometimes see it as they'll write
a delta Q which kind of implies change
in heat but I'll explain in a future
video well that doesn't make full sense
but you'll see this a lot but you can
also view this as the heat added to the
system minus the change in work which is
a little non-intuitive because when you
talk about heat or work you're talking
about transferring of energy so when you
talk about change in transfer it becomes
a little you know so sometimes the Delta
work they just mean this means that work
done work done by the system work done
so obviously if you have some if you
have some energy you do some work you've
lost that energy you've given to someone
else you'd have a minus sign there or
you might see it written like this
change in internal energy is equal to
heat added I won't say even this kind of
reads to me is change in heat I'll just
call this the heat added plus the work
the work done onto the system so this is
work work done too this is work done by
the system either way and you know you
you shouldn't even memorize this you
should just always think about it a
little bit if I'm doing work I'm going
to lose energy if work is done to me I'm
going to gain energy
if I lose heat if this is a negative
number I'm going to lose energy if I
gain heat I'm going to gain energy
anyway I'll leave you there for this
video in the next video we'll we'll
really try to digest this internal
energy formula in a hundred different
ways